so today I'm finally making the free
move Buju tutorial that I've been
promising you guys for a long time
first off we're gonna be doing this in
Buju there's a lot of programs out there
that do this kind of camera tracking
cynthaiz PF track motion tracker even
After Effects is built-in camera tracker
but bushu is one of the best and that's
I'm going to be showing you how to use
boo shoot the first step in tracking
your footage is to actually import your
footage into the program and the program
has some quirks in that it prefers high
quality JPEG sequences everything else
is a little iffy so if you X what your
footage is a jpg sequence that's the way
to go to start things off you have
toolbox view and you can see various
thumbnails for different things don't
see import sequence there's other ways
you can get access to these features you
can go to task view and you have the
same thing with cameras masks etc target
tracks you can also go to file and like
import through that way as well so start
in toolbox view we'll click on import
sequence then I'm going to navigate to
my image sequence select the first image
it open alright so here we have a couple
options here for the image sequence we
have our move type which is very
important we've done a nodal pan that's
easy now we're going to do a free move
and we have frame right now believe it
or not buzu actually doesn't really
differentiate between 23.976 and 24 this
can cause the slightest bit of drift
when you take things back into After
Effects 3ds max so it's worth keeping in
mind that any images or any video files
you've taken to bushu set them to be 24
frames per second instead of 23.976
it'll save yourself a little bit
headache and make things go well so I'm
going to set this to 24 inside the
program and then everything else is
basically fine
we hit OK alright so here we are working
with a shot from potion overdose the
shot is a great example of a free move
the camera is going all over the place
and there's actually a little geometry
up close to the camera with the dumpster
which you'll be able to see recreated
when we actually do the camera solve so
the very first step in a shot like this
is tracked features but before we do
that you have to ask yourself is there
any zoom am i doing any zooming with my
camera or with my lens for this shot is
known but if you did what you would do
is you double click in task view you
double click on focal length and then
there's an option or it says range
just double-click on that you drop it
down to varying that's all you have to
do if you have zooms I can make your
shot a little bit harder to solve for
the most part it's pretty
straightforward anyway so I leave it on
constant for this because it's a
constant shot
I don't zoom at all alright next up is
feature tracking so in toolbox you you
can click on track feature or in task
view you can just double click on
feature tracking it doesn't really
matter it's a little little window pops
up it's very similar to the nodal pan in
that you just simply track all your
features and that's step one
there's a couple things you can do if
you have a couple issues with this first
off if you have a lot of motion blur you
can increase your feature scale from
normal to large and look for larger
features rather than tinier high
contrast features same thing if you have
a shot that goes a little bit out of
focus larger features work better
secondly you have sensitivity which is
how many points it's putting on the
screen keep in mind just simply adding
more points will not necessarily make
things better because they need to be
good points while may be able to find a
lot more high points of contrast if you
have grainy footage for example they'll
be jumping all over the place and
finally you have search distance if you
have a shot that moves really fast
you might need to increase your search
distance because that's the area around
a point where it's going to look for
where it's moved to I'm just gonna leave
everything kind of that average for now
feature scale normal search distance 20%
bbm sensitivity you can see it has a
pretty good covering of the entire frame
I'm hit start and we wait now something
that's worth noting is you'll see me in
the foreground as the wizard and yet
there's no feature points on me so the
program is actually differentiating
between me in the background that's
because it has basic it has a basic
optical flow algorithm going on optical
flow is basically when a program
actually tracks the movement of the
various pixels and colors on the screen
it's not figuring out like any shape or
depth to it but it's able to tell that
the background pixels are moving in one
direction and the foreground pixels
where I am are moving another direction
it's pretty fancy pretty advanced but
for the most part what it means that you
don't actually have to worry about
masking off things in the program that
are moving if you do get trouble or you
do have some who fills the frame and you
see a lot of track points on them or on
any kind of moving subject you will need
to mask it off before you do a feature
track but in this case it worked great
so if I scroll up scrub through
you can see all these points with all
these trails and it's really confusing
so let's tone the trails down a little
bit just so you can see the points I'm
going to go over here on the right and
we have a list of various overlays and
things that we can see you see overlay
zoom target tracks you can solve erm etc
so I'm on the overlays tab tracks is
checked uncheck it tracks disappear I'll
check it tracks appear if I expand it
down you'll see I don't really have a
whole lot of options aside from checking
and unchecking things but up here I've
another little tracks with another
little checkbox there's two tracks and
two checkboxes check them both and it
lets you see the trails and you can
control how many frames the trails last
for so for example before you increase
or decrease after I can increase or
decrease or I can take them both down
and just have the points now one thing
that's worth noting is if just by
looking at the points if your brain if
your eyes kind of see shape to them if
you can see how the camera is moving
with just those points like I were to
take this background image out and just
be looking at the points and I can see
movement that's a good sign that the
computer will be able to solve your
track just fine
basically if your brain is able to
calculate depth from these points then
the computer can calculate depth from
these points if you just have like a
flat wall or you're just standing in
place and panning you're not actually
giving the program any depth data you're
not giving it multiple points that are
moving against each other that it can
use to solve the cameras position you
need to make sure that when you're doing
a shot for free move that you have
things that that you can track at
multiple distances and that the camera
is actually free moving if you stop and
you start doing a nodal pan and you turn
return to a free move generally things
will look okay but you're actually
losing all your depth data for the
moment when the camera stops moving
through space so that's worth
considering when you get a shot for free
move so this shot tracks great it's a
bright day everything is in focus I shot
with a high shutter speed it's pretty
much the perfect shot for blues you to
track but what if you start getting some
problems what if you like a tree in the
background there's wind blowing so the
tree is moving a little bit and it's all
tracked well there's different ways you
can tell buzu what points are good and
what points are bad
the very first way that's easiest is
with gold points so for example I'm
going to up my minimum here this is
going to get rid of any points that are
not on screen for the minimum number
frames and lift it all the way up to say
70 all right I'm going to get some
trails just so you can see them these
points here are on screen for 70 frames
and as if you watch them they're pretty
much sticking exactly where they're
supposed to be these are good high
quality points so I'm going to select a
couple in the background here I'm gonna
right-click on them we say gold but you
know what you don't wanna just do in one
plane you want to have them at different
depths of the camera so I'm going to
select a couple others here that on this
door much closer to the camera and make
those gold also making a gold point
track tells Buju that these are good
quality tracks I've looked them they are
exactly where they need to be and moves
you to try to make sure the other tracks
are as good as these ones and it'll kind
of use these for reference so after you
make gold tracks you actually need to
resolve your feature tracking you can do
that just by once again double clicking
on future tracking or by going to your
toolbox and clicking track features I'm
going to stay in task view I'm a double
click and feature tracking I just hit
start new feature tracking deletes any
original feature tracks Dada Dada yeah
okay whatever so now it's refeed
tracking with those gold points using
those as reference to make quality
feature tracks one good rule of thumb
and I didn't really do it here but one
good rule of thumb is that your gold
feature tracks there should always be
one gold feature track on frame at any
given moment so you'll want them to
overlap each other slightly like if
we're looking at one section and they
pan over to look at the other section
you're obviously going to lose the
points that you just panned away from
but ideally if you can bridge the gap
with a couple other points in the middle
by saying all these are all gold and
making sure they're all on screen at the
same time you'll be good alright so
we're done PG tracking with our new gold
points which in this chat wasn't
entirely necessary by showing you guys
how to do it in case you have problems
shots so if I scrub back through you'll
see that the gold points I have are
still there with their funky lighter
yellow colors I'm gonna turn my number
my minimum length for tracks down so all
the tracks are back on the screen but
we're not there yet feature tracking is
just the computer saying here's points
on the screen it doesn't know anything
about where the position is in 3d space
it doesn't know anything about where the
camera is in 3d space
so next step camera
so I'm just gonna double-click on camera
solves once again you can go to toolbox
and click camera solve they both do the
same thing double click on it this stuff
pops up by the way guys if using the
program for the first time read all the
words in the windows that pop up take
your time programs are made to be used
they're not made to be dense and
unapproachable anyways a sequence
sequence 1 yep options all frames by the
way there's this option to optimize
camera path smoothness I usually check
it I don't quite know what it does I
think it smooths it out a little bit but
whatever things always look better when
I check it alright anyways I hit start
so now it's calculating it tells me how
long it's going to take roughly 3
minutes or so the faster does a camera
solve the better your future tracks if
the computer is really chugging on the
cameras all that means it means it's
having a hard time trying to figure out
the position of the camera based upon
the features that you tracked so they'll
kind of you'll be able to kind of tell
where the problem spots are by looking
at the progress bar and seeing where
it's slowing down but in this case it's
clipping along just kind of churning
through it really no issues so it means
that we'll probably get a good solid
solve generally what happens when you
get a bad camera solve is you get a lot
of vibration and wiggle on the camera
I'm not sure if you ever seem like bad
motion capture like where something is
like a really crappy like motion capture
Sudan or some like that and like the raw
data like they're kind of like wigglin
kind of like the Kinect yeah that's
kinda what happens if you have a bad
cameras all the cameras solve is all
done and I have all these blue and
yellow points on my screen I scrub
around oh they're actually sticking to
the screen i scrub slowly they're
actually sticking to the screen quite
well suppose you guys are wondering what
those yellow points mean versus the blue
points yellow points are the points that
are informing the cameras position at
that frame so for example if I'm looking
at this frame here of down the alley all
the yellow points on the gate and the
points that are down in the alley that
are yellow those points are being used
at that moment in time to inform the
program where the camera is all the
other blue points are not being used at
the time but if we scrub through i scrub
through we will see that those points
those blue points turn yellow later on
because they are being used later on
these frames now you can tell us a good
solve because those blue points which
are not being used are still in the
right spot and are tracking to the
footage correctly also up here we have
some buttons to e3d orthographic I click
3d I get to see my scene in 3d and you
hold shift and left-click to rotate the
cameras point of view yield shift and
middle click with the mouse wheel to pan
field shift and you right click to zoom
in and out and you can see the whole
scene here in fact if i zoom in I can
actually see the dumpster right here
which is pretty nuts that the dumpsters
been recreated in a point cloud in 3d
space I can also see the wall down the
alleyway it's actually really cool that
this program is managed to create scene
geometry from this footage what's the
next step this looks like a totally
great camera solve looking at my camera
its path is smooth it's not jittering
all over the place in fact it looks
pretty accurate to what I did in real
life so what's the next step here well
the very next step is to take your scene
and align it to the axes because for
example we have ground that we might
want to put it in 3ds max or you might
want to put decals on the wall and
after-effects and it's a lot easier to
do that if everything is lined up with
the XY and z coordinates so here's how
you do that up here at the top of a
button and it says edit coordinate
system or test objects right now we're
on the test object system where you can
actually put objects in the scene and
make sure they track I'm going to click
that and now we're in the coordinate
system and you can only do two things
translate and rotate I want to rotate
and the very first thing I'm going to do
is just kind of line up my view here on
the side line my ground by rotating
pretty good I'm going to go to move mode
move it up to ground level and you
notice I'm just kind of doing this in 3d
view that's fine you can do it in like
the orthographic views and that kind of
stuff but this is quick and easy
alright so my ground is pretty much
lined up next up I need to line up my
wall so I'm lining it up looks good
looks good
alright so now my scene is all lined up
so in 3d everything matches the
coordinate system in 2d everything
sticks I could add a test object if I
want but I'm
gonna cuz I don't need to you guys can
look at the manual to figure out how to
do that and now it's time to export so
I'm gonna cover export into two
different programs after effects and
3dsmax if you're using another program
like Maya or blender or cinema 4d or
what have you the process is basically
the same the only thing you'll really
have to worry about is how it's managing
your units of scale for example when you
export this the program doesn't know how
big the scene was just by watching the
video it doesn't know if if this alley
is a foot long or a hundred feet long
and you can tell it in the program by
setting a scale but I find it's much
easier just to take it into your program
of choice and scale it there so all we
need to do is make sure that when we're
going to these programs you're going to
quit making all the noise I'm trying to
record a tutorial here's a really nice
well we need to make sure that happens
is that our skill is in a workable size
let me go into these programs from there
we can change it however we need so
first things first I'm going to go to
After Effects now all these points are
actually going to export as nulls into
After Effects and that's a lot of nulls
it'll kind of bog down the program
so I'm just going to select a couple I
select a couple on the ground a couple
on the gate a couple on the dumpster
just enough so I can kind of know where
things are my scene all right next up
with these points selected I'm going to
right click on one of them and go to
flag for export which Flags import
exporting all right so export the top
menu I click on that I go to export
camisole file name I'll actually Ivan
save this file yet check this out guys
if you save your project save as I'm
gonna save on desktop some baller
all right we call this free movin all
right if you save your file and you go
to export camera solve to automatically
name a camera solve the same thing and
put it in the same spot which is great
very convenient so free movement MA aka
Maya aka after-effects Maya
after-effects actually can read the same
camera data which is pretty great so
export type after-effects now what we
want to do export or flag tracks only so
I don't have a million nulls in the
screen start film is good and frame is
good ah scale seen by so after effects
measure its its scale and pics
and that's all it does so with our skill
being one-to-one right now it's going to
be very tiny when it goes into After
Effects it would be like 10 pixels wide
always scale your scene for After
Effects by a thousand you don't be tiny
there's a way to fix that create a null
you parent all the camera and null
points to that parent null and you scalp
that parent null and you'll scale the
entire scene relative to itself
it'll be okay but save yourself a
headache enter a scale seen by of
thousand Oh moving camera static scene
that's generally what you want it's
going to have all the points be static
and you can't will be moving save that's
it it's ready for After Effects now what
if you're going into a 3d program like
3ds max well basically the same process
export camera solve an export type
drop-down we'll pick a 3d studio max you
don't have to export flag tracks 3d
studio max can handle thousands of
points just fine so I'd recommend
keeping all of them and scale scene by
well it's really easy to scale things in
3ds max but I just say make it 100 it
makes it a little bit bigger a little
bit easier to work with um one thing
that's worth noting is 3ds max has the x
y&z axis on different orientations than
After Effects so your scene might come
in upside down or like pointed at the
ground or whatever that's fine just on
your first frame just rotate the whole
scene 90 degrees realign it and
everything will be perfect it's also
worth noting that buzu starts on frame 1
other programs like 3ds max tend to
start in frame 0 so if your image
sequence is like misaligned and the
points will seem to like link up same
thing in After Effects it probably means
that your starting frame is off by one
so shift it around alright sorry I'm in
After Effects
alright I have my image sequence Oh put
its that 23.976 well as earlier 24
frames per second is what buzu does so
it's interpreter footage go to main
assume this frame wait 24 all right if
you don't do this it's not the end of
the world it's the tiniest drift but if
you want a really rock-solid drift
everything has to be 24 frames per
second alright create new sequence by
clicking the image sequence and dragging
it down to create a new composition
there we are
me pretending to barf all over the place
alright time to import the camera just
simply double-clicking the space to
import it we're going to the desktop
where I got my free move I select that
alright it creates a composition called
free movement where we see all these
nulls and there's a camera alright so I
got to do is take all these select them
copy them and paste them into my
composition and there they are if you
look at the nulls they stick everything
sticks because we have a 3d camera
moving in 3d space the exact same way
that we did it in real life and that's
how you get a good camera track now
let's say you want to add something to
the scene but simple let's create a
solid alright got a new solid here I'm
going to make it 3d by clicking this
little box and I want to line it up to
those nulls if I want to make it appear
to stick so let's say let's say I want
that solid to be on the ground right so
let me just select a null that's on the
ground there's an uhlet's on the ground
alright so the easiest way for me to do
this let's just do it by eye so now my
solid is lined up with those nulls which
means it's basically on the ground here
I can see it in the main view that is
indeed on the ground as long as I do not
move it off the y-axis it should be
effectively on the ground it's very
important to note in a nodal pan if you
put something in the frame it sticks no
matter where it is carries in one spot
you're just panning around and a free
move it is very important that whatever
object you're putting in is in the
correct 3d space for example this could
look like it's on the ground but it
might actually be very below the ground
and far back it's just a trick of
perspective so you actually need to make
sure that it's position is exactly where
it needs to be otherwise it will appear
to drift if I scrub through it does
indeed stick to the ground
let me demonstrate the other issue let
me lower this move it so right now it
still looks like it's on the ground
right if I move it doesn't stick
and see it drifting I'll make even more
severe still appears like it's on the
ground it still appears like it's in the
same spot once again if I move see how
drifts that's because it's hot into the
correct 3d spot it's actually like 20
feet below the ground and you're just
you're seeing it because there's
actually no real ground blocking it it's
very important that things are in the
correct spot in 3d space you use your
nulls as a reference for that so you got
a sweet camera solve your having match
effects for 3ds Max or whatever program
you want the objects are sticking looks
great sweet good for you
nice work I guarantee at some point in
the future you're gonna get a shot and
you're not gonna be able to solve it
it's going to be blurry it might be dark
and grainy and you're just pulling your
hair out trying to get to work you can't
go out and get the shot again you had
all the people you needed for that one
moment and the shots not working what do
you do if you're not because bushu is a
very powerful program i'll show you how
you fix that I'm gonna go back to Boozer
here
I mean delete the scanner solve just
starting over so I have my future tracks
and let's say they're a high quality
future tracks the program's having a
hard time solving the scene here's what
you do so here's what you do if you have
a very hard to solve track you go to
toolbox tab you click the add target
track button and you click on some point
of high contrast in your scene if you
can find it I'm just clearing the edges
Oh or whatever that is and this works
just like the point tracker in After
Effects so basically set your size of
the point that's tracking in the area
around it that's going to be following
or trying to follow done here on the
right the TT tab stands for target track
I can go forward a frame and sticking to
it or I can go forward many frames just
let it play up you see there it jumped
from that corner to that corner so I'm
going to go back there's the jump
and I can use the arrow keys for
frame-by-frame and it's going to click
back in the corner to put it back on the
slot and then I can track forward and
I'm fine so now if I go down to this
Timeline view and I expand target tracks
here is my target track here so let's
say at this point I walked across camera
and you couldn't see the target track
anymore I'd add a keyframe to the
current frame and then if there's
anything else beyond it I would right
click in that area and either clear it
or if it's obscured and it reappears
I'd say set range occlusion so for
example let's say my hand pass in from
the camera and then reappears or in that
point becomes visible again and click on
the corner again and you see this little
gap in tracking right click and there I
say set range occlusion but the means is
for that span that point has been
included by something passing in front
of it so the program will know that it's
the same point not a different point but
the same point that reappears later on
now I can continue tracking that point
if you have at least three to four
target tracks on screen at all time
you're practically guaranteed have a
camera solve so even though the shots
all blurry now to focus in all grainy as
long as you using your eyes can follow a
couple points on screen and place target
tracks on them you can pretty much track
anything so target tracks are where the
real power of the program comes in if
you want to learn more about them just
open the manual it talks about all the
various numbers what they mean and all
the various like options that you have
for the most part just imagine it like
point tracks and after effects you just
follow a point place another target
track follow point if you want place a
new target track just click the button
again you click somewhere else if you
want select an old target track right
down here this little button called
toggle edit mode I hit that I'm no
longer in edit mode for the target track
I can go ahead and select a different
target track so that little toggle edit
mode is how you get out of selecting one
target track
selecting another target track you can
go back into edit mode and mess around
with your points that's it guys this
basically lets you make high-level
professional official effect shots you
can track anything you want to a scene
the world is here is to command use the
power responsibly leaks out
you